and the Oscar goes to GMO nav
[Applause]
[Music]
for it's all about film language so it's
the story told with images and that it's
a camera that is looking that is
searching and it's finding their entire
scenes that are just
images we want you to believe that is
this Her Imagination is this really
happening is not can we really Go in
different borts and cross avenues like
that and then this movie teaches us yes
for that you have to allow the language
to guide
you something that was very important
for us in this movie was that from the
get-go we have to bring the audience in
a conf comtable space where that
parallel reality was there it was
familiar we could just step in and out
of
it the the girl ofilia could easily walk
in and out of that parallel
reality I think that color is incredibly
important it conveys emotion and it
conveys a sense of energy and it conveys
a tail when you code it carefully at the
end of the day we end up with a color
pallette and we say if it's not in this
pallette it's not in the movie the real
universe is much more muted colors and
cold colors in many cases how the
intermediate world like the pit in the
center of the labyrinth is green the
fantasy world is golden and red you know
and and it's warmer and uterine there
are images that that somehow we know
they're going to be part of that
universe that's also the spaces and the
symbols and it's really like material
like the clay that you have to work with
for that we had to take the risks of
going and doing things that uh were
artificial in a way but that allowed all
this craziness to
[Music]
belong this award is a recognition for
the collective effort to support the
vision of the genius of yoro to my
children to my wife for giving me wings
thank you very
[Applause]
[Music]
much